the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu call ourselves blue steel so
one thing you might be asking yourselves
and wondering for buses where did we get
the name blue steel what does it have to
do with this thing we call ray tracing
and this morning when I was sitting up
and finishing up the project I was
asking myself the same thing we're doing
ray tracing where did we come up with
this name so I'm going to give you a
little background on what blue steel is
the name the name came from the first
day we got access to our ps3 we went to
the student center like a bunch of
excited kids on Christmas and what did
we do we created a mailing list for our
group didn't even mess with the ps3 just
created the mailing list and took sit
that SAT there for about an hour and a
half thinking of a name and somehow we
decided on Zoolander's famous face blue
steel and it's didn't have particular
significance to us before but as you'll
see it has a lot of historical value
blue steel is also an alloy a first
alloy as you can see it's a we have blue
tempered spring steel that are many
companies industries use and blue steel
is also a a warhead made in the Cold War
but these have nothing to do with our
with our project to us and for the
purpose of this project blue steel is a
distributed real-time ray tracer and
Natalia is going to give you a little
background of what
it really is thank you so retracing
there are two types of two terms that
you would generally here ray tracing and
Ray casting basically the idea is the
camera is like the eye and from the
camera rays are cast for each pixel in a
picture and these Ray's they intersect
with all the virtual objects in the
scene when an object is hit the the
color of it is computed the closest
object that is intersected is the object
that shows up on the screen and ray
tracing is recursive it accounts for
shadows positions other objects in the
scene there is a reflection and
refraction for example if this way we
could hit that object and is reflected
then another way is cast from that
object in the reflecting direction and
this can go on for an indefinite number
of reflections these are normally
specified in the program here's an
example of the recursion so the three
planes are reflective there are mirrors
and there
years between them with no recursion you
can see there is no reflection at all
with one recursion you can see there the
Rays are reflecting just off the side
meters at the end with two recursions
there's also reflection at the bottom so
it is a reflection of one of the
reflections and this is very
computationally intensive because for
every pixel you're casting array and for
every object in the scene you're
intersecting that Ray with the object
and seeing if it's hit and then if it is
hit and it is reflective or refractive
so transparent then another way is cast
this scene here is a resolution 1024 x
1024 and recursion depth is 100 and the
rendering time in our program was 2.6
seconds the rendering time for 20 depth
recursion was 600 milliseconds and for
10 was 300 milliseconds many of us
obtained in six 837 and in that class we
we all built racers and a typical seemed
like the one that is on the power point
right now could take up to a minute or
more often if you include if you were to
do a hundred bounces I think mine would
probably taken over tenant
well we did try different SP use of this
picture we didn't try with different
SPU's but we have tried other scenes
with various numbers and we did get
exact linear speed-up so if there were
twice as many CPUs it would be twice as
fast and okay Natalia's told you about
retrace departed we are focused honest
and meeting that goal in real time and
for us real time you chapter you have to
ask what is real time if we go off of
Lake of the American video standard ntsc
they define that to be around 27 30
frames a second so that was pretty much
the goal that we set when we set out to
do this and so we took the code and we
think okay we can split this this task
is easily paralyzed about but we're
gonna have to do a lot more than that if
we want to get it better if we want to
get better rates so we took advantage of
the hardware that we were wrong and one
thing that we did on the ray tracing end
we had to go crazy with was Cindy
they're pretty much the entire ray
tracer never deals with a scalar value
we use sim day for everything and in the
core of it there are we do branch
avoidance so we really try not not to
take branches because branch mrs. are
very costly on the cell so I believe
there's something like three if
statements spread across four thousand
lines of code for the red tracer we
really took the sinabi to heart in this
we said so the representing using Cindy
you can
process you know arrays of structures so
we we took okay we we took we trace we
retrace ray packets of four grayza two
at a time and from those ray packets we
would generate hit packets and then
similarly as you go down the line we
would produce an RGB packet which is a
color for color values tied into one so
at every step we would use simdi to our
advantage now brands going to talk to
you about pipelining so a particular
focus on the cell is not only what I
start soon as you execute but the order
that you have to keep them in because
there is no reader going so there's a
lot more execution and despite the fact
that compiler technology is very good
hand optimization and pipelining
instructions is still always better for
instance with our triangle intersection
routine we regained on the order of
hundreds of milliseconds of render time
we shaved hundreds of milliseconds
around of time off of our render time
for some scenes you will see later just
by reordering our calculations in the
intersection code so it's very important
especially on the SP es and one other
optimization we made was the fact that
we didn't we coded basically everything
on the SP es anything running on the
ESPYs is coded in c not in c++ and we're
not using inheritance when we do you c
plus plus because virtual functions have
more overhead with respect to memory the
v table and also looking up the function
pointers from the v table so these are
just a couple of the optimizations we
made we'll talk about more later
pipeline you actually reorder
instructions statements not the
compilers it wasn't very helpful yeah so
I am on that scene 1024 x 1024 with the
spheres we were getting natalia
mentioned with a depth of record of
recursion of 10 we were getting 300
milliseconds that's with optimized
without the optimizations we were
getting closer to 500 with a depth of
recursion and this with a depth of
recursion of 10 and
this we gain that extra 200 milliseconds
just by reordering instructions in the
intersection with optimization level 0 3
in xlc so hand optimization like Mike
acton said in class is still very
important and I'm going to add you up
Mikey now to discuss the regular grid
all right so one of the problems i guess
but very tracings intersections are very
expensive and we have you know scenes
with n raise and M primitives way up to
generate any times and intersections so
one commonly acceleration structure is a
grip and then the concept is very simple
as pictures of pets you just take your
screen split it up into a number of
evenly sized box holes place your
primitives in them and then you march
your way through and you only intersect
the ray with with primitives that are
around the area and the good thing about
a grid is that it's very easy to
construct as opposed to like say a KD
tree or an octree those take on the
order of n log n or ends the number of
primitives a regular grid is order n
where n is number of primitives and the
reason why we did this is because when
an interactive seen you need to where
things are moving around you need to
rebuild the grid every frame or whenever
something moves so we favored this this
choice of acceleration structure because
it was quick to build and easy to
traverse and now
all right I was in charge of building
the excitation our original plan was to
do the 6 170 well known gizmo ball in 3d
and ray traced and ok I have it running
on this laptop we didn't quite get it
ray traced but I was going to show you a
little bit of what i did is the physics
engine
maybe not
okay um anyway anyway it was basically a
to an FD version of the example that was
just up on the screen flippers work
absorbers work and due to complications
we never did get it fully retraced and I
guess we'll go ahead and give me the
real Rick first endless which we do have
a couple of those fortunately ps3
slipping kind of digital connection to
display things in the right resolution
when you're writing through frame buffer
so we can't project it on turn
well now you gotta tell hey no no wrong
way ready when you still adjusting it oh
oh no okay we prepared if we prepared a
few demos for you and these are really
just going to show off the ray tracing
part of it and this sort of you know
Rachel that we got in terms of ours the
after we applied our speed ups here is a
thank you here we see you know that both
the camera is moving and we have we
implemented full scene functional
textures so you see the checkerboard
it's generated every frame it's you know
we use no texture maps this is
completely generated functionally bump
mapping as you can see in the large
orange sphere is also done on the fly as
well as blending between two two
textures using Perlin noise is done on
the fly also showcased in the center
sphere right here you can see both
reflection and refraction spheres
transparent it acts as a glass sphere so
you can see the reflection of the orange
in it but also the warping of the
checkerboard as it goes through this is
one of the advantages of while spheres
are part of one of the advantages of ray
tracing because you get you can use a
geometrical equations to define your
geometry versus and using rasterization
methods you have to actually define the
geometry in some sort of concrete
numerical way i'm going to go to the
next demo this should showcase some of
the lights that we implemented so how
many frames per second if this link this
is this should be 15 frames a second and
this let me reiterate this is with the
the refraction step requires at least
two bounces set two steps of recursion
if we were to turn off this record if we
were to turn that off we would be
achieving
i would estimate twenty seven frames a
second 28 but then it doesn't look as
pretty asserting that what's the point
you can see kind of this will be
showcased later but you can see the
spotlight it's kind of moving it's
waving back and forth eliminating parts
of the scene there's also a point light
at some distance around here that's
eliminating everything but it's
basically the same set of primitives if
you were closer you could probably
notice that the checkerboard is fully
reflective you can view the scene that
this far wall you can view the entire
scene in it can go to the next demo this
is with the lights off so you can get a
better better sense of what the
spotlight is actually doing if you
notice on this orange sphere we
implemented a very two different forms
of BRD fs1 was generic phong shading and
then the other was cooked torrance which
is helps using particularly with metals
and other materials like that it helps
have very bright you know specular
highlight and you'll notice as the as
the cameras panning back and forth the
sort of speed ups that we get from as
the we took advantage of certain we used
a little trick state to glean speed here
and there like you know when it's when
it's so dark or it's very far away we
just we stop a person so we are ok ah
let's do the MSP for more okay I can
demonstrate the we actually enabled it
so that you can turn it on either you
know one through six ESPYs using command
line arguments so if I thought let's go
to back to the first demo if I say just
use one SPE we can watch it you know
slowly trot along and if I were SSH
dinner would be giving me you know
timing information so i could tell you
exactly it's really unfortunate that's
not because it's very linear and it's
yeah right now it'll be it says you know
500 milliseconds but if I turn it on to
it drops literally in half to 2 50 you
can get a sense of that from that it's
moving like tick tick tick tick versus
tick tick tick and then three two
similar speed up and then I'll jump to
five it's getting closer and then when
we turn on the sixth it's a this is this
should be about 12 15 frames a second so
you listen if you had a dozen sVU's you
can go reach actually it's running
mentioned Latvia I think it was at the
Julia raytracer or the IRT that both of
them used to sell blades which is a full
eight it's simply eight cores pretends
to so they use 16 SPU's the PlayStation
3 due to certain factors we're only
limited to six is the way you're
dividing up the work you know each SPU
taking once you know every sixth
restaurant basically that sounds like
can you improve on the performance by by
allocating the race there's a whole the
issue there is one of a granularity of
our distribution and also communication
town on the bus we can definitely we can
we've designed it such that we can fine
tune it in any way we want but it seems
to me that you had a kind of a localized
bundle of rays you know on a single sbu
you might be able to do some
optimizations like treat them as fat
rape you know near near x rays are
likely to intersect the same try amity
crossing right the the entire material
system works very much like that it
actually saves on computation based on
which raised of the of the in a packet
of four have hit have collided with the
same element and you know if it does and
it takes full advantage of cindy to
quickly you know chug through those
those rays that are the same and then
never call that particular shader again
because it's already done work for them
another issue i think i'm sorry we
should try to wrap up so that we can get
through the others any more very short
questions all right did you guys have
any last concluding statements dr.
drastic well no no alright so maybe a
two-key thank you